Superman who Dwayne Johnson seems poised
to turn the DC Universe upside down with
the release of Black Adam next week at
least according to those who've already
seen the movie early reviews for the
Warner Brothers flick have it pegged as
an overwhelmingly brutal and honest take
on the Black Adam character who
literally kills anyone and everyone in
his way perk collider Stephen Weintraub
he wrote in his review Johnson's
fantastic as Black Adam and I loved that
he didn't pull back on who Black Adam is
for those who might not know DC's Black
Adam seemed destined to fail in many
people's eyes with all the woes that
Warner Brothers has experienced as of
late back in March the film was
reportedly pushed back from a summer
release to October 21st 2022 due to
covet related production delays
involving its visual effects producer
Hiram Garcia explained the situation for
the rap saying I think we're just in a
world right now where there was a huge
and understandable freeze up when the
pandemic hit and a lot of Productions
were put on hold now that the industry
has really reward back the pipeline for
VFX is so jammed and we're just in a
situation where the majority of VFX
houses are just completely swamped with
work with this in mind many people fear
that Black Adam was doomed to fail in
the eyes of critics and audiences but
according to people who got early
screenings of Black Adam the DC film is
unlike any comic book movie that's come
before it with one critic even
describing it as a 300 style action
spectacle critic Paul McGuire Grimes
tweeted that it was quote Epic on every
level similarly screen Ranch Joe
deckelmeyer tweeted Black Adam is a game
changer Dwayne Johnson is electrifyingly
brutal as Black Adam the action in the
film is Non-Stop and seeing the Justice
Society of America on the big screen was
a thrill while it definitely looks like
there are a few things in the movie
worth griping about the overall
consensus for Black Adam seems to be
that it's a possible scale Tipper for
DC's extended Universe following
Marvel's recent missteps with critically
lukewarm film films like black widow
eternals doctor strange and the
Multiverse of Madness and Thor love and
thunder some people have even wondered
if fans are getting tired of Marvel
movies now in the wake of the conclusion
to the decade-long infinity Saga if
early reviews of Black Adam are true
then Johnson may not have been ambitious
enough when he said this sentiment the
hierarchy of power in the DC Universe
is about to change for many reviewers
DC's Black Adam isn't just a breath of
fresh air for the Hollywood superhero
genre but all of the dceu as a whole Ben
Rolfe of discussing film tweeted Black
Adam is DC's most action-packed film to
date it's a Non-Stop Thrill Ride that is
all about spectacle and it knows it he
also added Dwayne Johnson is a perfect
Black Adam plus Pierce Brosnan is a
standout content creator and
entertainment journalist Matt Ramos
hasn't seen Black Adam yet but he fully
expects the film to help shift the tide
for Warner Brothers and DC films on
October 12th Ramos tweeted if Black Adam
is as great as the review say DC might
have slammed Marvel this year in a
separate tweet which came later in the
night as more and more reviews for Black
Adam rolled in Ramos declared quote DC
is back while the Marvel vs DC rivalry
may be fun for fans and critics it's
something that the movie stars
themselves apparently don't pay much
mind to or at least that's how Dwayne
Johnson sees it I kneel before no one in
an October 12th interview at the New
York City premiere of Black Adam he told
the Associated Press do I think we are
going to take any kind of bite out of
Marvel that answer is unequivocally no
Johnson added we don't want to be Marvel
we want to be DC and how we do things so
that's what I want I don't want to take
a bite of that apple I want to grab a
new Apple and I want to create from
there
[Music]
foreign